hi I'm Zack Weiss molar for recent TV
coming to you from the Democratic
National Convention in Philadelphia
where we've heard Democrats talk a lot
about new federal programs they'd like
to implement expand Social Security
strengthen Medicare paid family leave go
to a public college or university
tuition free but we haven't heard much
talking about the cost of those programs
and what they'll do to the national debt
so we're gonna ask Democrats whether
they are concerned about the national
debt and how they plan to pay for their
new programs so we should have paid
maternity leave and paid paternity leave
I would like to see an expansion on the
Affordable Care Act free public tuition
for something like mandatory paid leave
the price tag on that's about estimated
around a trillion dollars a year or for
free college tuition between 350 and 450
billion a year does the price tag
concern you we have the richest country
in the world today we're the richest
country in history it's not a matter of
the lack of money does debt worry a
federal debt no dude Democrats care
about the national debt yeah I think
they do I think Republicans and
Democrats do but I also think we need to
realize that we don't manage the budget
of a country like we would balance our
checkbook it's fine to have debt we need
to look at the GDP to debt ratio over
the Obama administration the debts gone
up by about 56 percent the pretty sharp
increase I'm sure I don't know what the
numbers are before that it's gone up
under let's be honest every
administration in both of our lifetimes
I didn't really hear much talk about the
debt in there and to be honest I didn't
hear it much at the Republican National
Convention either as a younger person
seeing what death has done to some of
the other countries in Europe does the
issue of national debt concern you at
all I mean
I'm not a econ major so it's not
something I think about all the time I
think we care about what could happen if
the debt became completely out of
control what we seem to be seeing now is
a situation where while the debt has
increased it's done so in a way while
the deficit has also gone down during
the Obama administration so that means
it's growing at a slower rate obviously
that's the ultimate goal and it
increased by 56 percent during the Obama
administration right but the return on
that has meant that the with more people
working more people paying tax dollars
because they're working means that our
deficit growth has slowed way way way
down bring all the troops home reduce
the military budget by at least 1/2 and
then use that money to invest in the
infrastructure the military budget
that's a decent point but it's only
gonna pay for a fraction of our existing
debt plus the new program stop the
hemorrhaging and the increasing of the
national debt by making sure that the
wealthy in our country the 1% pay their
fair share we really need to make sure
that corporations are paying their fair
share of taxes Hilary has her
progressive taxes
that she's claiming on doing tonight
historically the United States hasn't
really been able to take in more than 19
percent of GDP and so no matter how high
the tax rates are on the richest people
it depends on how big the GDP is does
that change your perspective on the
ability to raise that kind of revenue
well thank you for raising that
analytical point that's another call for
the expansion of our economy or the
increase of the GDP but again the money
that is being generated by this greater
productivity needs to be invested in the
American future the places where they
have been able to take in more revenue
our the Nordic countries where they
increase taxes on the middle class as
well as the richest people would you be
in favor of middle class tax hike I mean
to an extent I feel like the middle
class is already feeling the pressure as
it is I don't know if it would be a
necessarily a middle class income tax
increase but I do think there are ways
for everyone to have skin in the game
and I know that's work sometimes in
California when we've had bonds and
parcel taxes how can we address things
like the national debt when we're still
trying to you know restrict people's
right to vote restricting the woman's
right to choose even though the Supreme
Court has continued to uphold it if
we're looking at a choice between
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump and
we're talking to our viewers about this
issue of debt do you think that Hillary
Clinton is the one to solve these
problems I don't even think that is the
biggest issue by far